hey here's very interesting news
the next alex jones defamation trial is
starting now i know many of you are
probably thinking david we we just had
the defamation trial
what do you mean alex jones there was a
judgment against him for 50 million you
interviewed me i interviewed the
attorney mark bankston well remember
mark bankston told us that was only the
first of many trials and the associated
press is now reporting trial set to
begin for alex jones in sandy hook case
a month after losing one nearly 50
million dollar verdict
conspiracy theorist alex jones is set to
go on trial a second time for calling
the sandy hook elementary school
shooting a hoax and causing several of
the victims families emotional and
psychological harm
a six-member jury with several
alternates in connecticut will begin
hearing evidence tuesday on how much
jones should pay the families since he
already has been found liable for
damages to them the trial is expected to
last about four weeks
last month a texas jury ordered jones to
pay 49.3 million to the parents of
six-year-old jesse lewis one of 26
students and teachers killed in the 2012
shooting in newtown connecticut jones
lawyers
uh jones lawyer said an appeal is
planned this is going to get really bad
this could be the end of alex jones and
infowars and i have to tell you the
world would be better off
if that were the case
the connecticut case has the potential
for an even larger award than the 50
million because it involves three
lawsuits which have been consolidated
that were filed by 15 plaintiffs
including the relatives of nine of the
victims and a former fbi agent who
responded to the shooting this is going
to be a really big deal and the best and
most
fair if we want to talk about justice
the most just thing that can happen here
is for alex jones to have to pay
uh all of these victims for what he did
and uh this may end infowars that's true
uh at the same time
alex jones immediately started
fundraising on the last verdict and
roger stone recorded videos supporting
alex jones fundraising on that verdict
and um
it's not clear
that this is it for his followers it
actually may be
motivating his followers from from just
little spits and spurts that i've been
seeing on twitter and elsewhere
some of the infowars audience is quite
motivated to donate and to buy
whatever stuff alex jones is selling on
the basis of what they believe is a
completely unfair verdict so i don't
think it is obvious yet that this is the
end for alex jones and infowars but mark
bankston uh the lawyer the plaintiff's
lawyer who we interviewed not long ago
he told me i probably don't have a
definite remember alex jones has
attacked me i don't know how many of you
guys remember that thank your lucky
stars every day you're not dave pacman
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad pac-man's a loser
yeah unfortunately that according to
mark bankston does not raise my case to
the point of defamation but
this is probably going to clean out alex
jones even if there are
comparatively smaller verdicts there are
so many plaintiffs in this next case
this could be the end and we will be
covering it and we will see what happens